[Musik]
ja schlimme Bilder aus der Ukraine nicht
nur aus Kiew sondern aus 20 Städten des
Landes wo Russland heute morgen massive
Angriffe geflogen hat bzw ausgeführt hat
wir sehen uns die Bilder von heute
morgen aus Kiew noch einmal an hier also
die ersten großen Explosionen es war
ungefähr 8 Uhr hier war Zeit als
nacheinander verschiedene
marschflowkörper Selbstmord Drohnen aus
bzw Kamikaze Drohnen eingeschlagen sind
und wir wissen mittlerweile dass es mehr
als 40 Angriffe der Russen gegeben hat
angeblich 30 Master Körper sollten
abgefangen worden sein von der
ukrainischen Luftabwehr aber wir wissen
dass es auch mal zahlreiche Einschläge
gehabt und wir können hier einfach mal
gucken das ist ein Park in Kiew hier
haben wir einen riesigen Krater und die
Hinterhand haben wir ein Spielplatz ja
also es ist ein Spielplatz direkt im
Herzen von Kiew und wir sehen noch mal
das wie wie nah der sozusagen hier an
erfolgt ist der Angriff insgesamt haben
wir mindestens acht Tote heute morgen in
Kiew das ist aber nur eine Zahl die wir
von vor zwei Stunden gehört haben mit
mittlerweile sind es wesentlich mehr und
das ganze können wir uns auch gleich mal
auf der Karte ansehen wir haben Angriffe
nicht nur hier im Norden des Landes in
Kiew sondern wir haben auch live im
Westen hier was angegriffen wurde wir
haben und deshalb wir haben Ternopil wir
haben verschiedene Städte auch im Osten
nämlich zum Beispiel saporisha hier ganz
unten und die Neapel bzw angegriffen
wurden sämtliche ukrainische Großstädte
wurden heute im Laufe des Vormittags
angegriffen aus aus der Luft und zwar
zum einen wie gesagt von Shahid 136
Kamikaze drohen die sollen aus Belarus
hier oben gekommen sein und den
kürzesten Weg genommen haben nach Kiew
allerdings auch von
ch101 marschflowkörpern die von
russischen strategischen Bomben
abgefeuert wurden und auch von Calibre
Marge für Körpern die hier aus dem
Schwarzen Meer und wir hören auch aus
dem Kaspischen Meer abgeschossen wurden
zahlreiche Einschläge ja und warum
passiert das das ist die große Frage wir
wissen dass vor zwei Tagen die
krim-brücke die
Schlagader der militärischen Versorgung
Russlands auf der Krim und in
Südrussland hier angegriffen wurde von
wem auch immer Russland sagt die Ukraine
steckt dahinter offiziell wo das bislang
nicht bestätigt und direkt danach hat
Putin einen neuen general ernannt für
den gesamten Ukraine Krieg und zwar ein
herrens Herr gay sukowirien ist okay ist
ja Games und kurvigerin der bereits in
Syrien sich einen Namen gemacht hat und
dort das Blatt umgerissen hat für
Diktator Assad
dort mit massiven Luftangriffen auf die
zivile Infrastruktur in den
rebellengebieten es geschafft hat das
Rückgrat der Rebellen das Rückgrat der
Menschen dort zu brechen und wir sehen
was direkt nach diesem Angriff passiert
sind das Bilder von saporisha aus dem
Morgen nach dem nach dem krimbrücken
Angriff dort scheint es weiterzugehen
der neue General von Putin hat offenbar
nicht nur militärische Ziele im Blick
bzw fast gar nicht militärischen Ziel im
Blick dann was wir heute morgen in Kiew
gesehen haben war reiner Terror gegen
Zivilisten und auch diese Brücke hier
wir erinnern uns an die krimbrück auch
diese Brücke hier im Herzen Kiews wurde
heute morgen angegriffen wir sehen eine
Überwachungskamera jetzt eine riesige
Explosion das ist eine reine
touristenbrücke auf der ich selbst schon
mehrmals lang gelaufen bin einige Fotos
gemacht habe das hat nichts mit Verkehr
zu tun nichts mit Militär zu tun dort
gehen nur Touristen lang um die schöne
Aussicht zu genießen nicht einmal Autos
können darüber fahren und wir sehen auch
gleich das am Morgen 8:19 Uhr merken uns
das mal eine weitere Kamera hier das
gleich noch aufnimmt hier ist ein Mensch
der da einfach rüber geht am frühen
Morgen hier auch sehen wir morgen um
8:18 Uhr die Zeit und wir sehen jetzt
hier auf der linken Seite diese große
Explosion die gleich stattfindet
also einfach nur symbolische Akte auch
die eben krimbrücke jetzt diese Brücke
in Kiew offenbar angegriffen wurden aber
das sind nicht die einzigen Ziele wir
wissen dass ein zahlreichen Metropolen
der Ukraine heute Stromausfall herrscht
Stromausfall deshalb weil in Lewis weil
in rakiv weil in Kiew Strom Erzeugung
angegriffen wurde das heißt wir haben
hier ein ja ein vernicht der noch mal
eine Stufe weitergetrieben wird nämlich
eben jetzt gegen die Zivilbevölkerung
und gegen die Menschen hier jetzt weder
Wärme noch Strom haben in zahlreichen
Städten eine Sache wollen wir uns noch
angucken nämlich zum Thema Schlachtfeld
denn eigentlich geht ja auch dort der
Krieg weiter und wie stark mittlerweile
dort die Ukraine ist und wie man
überhaupt keine Angst mehr hat vor
Russland sieht man an diesen Aufnahmen
hier wird eine ukrainische Arterie
benutzt eine m77 aus den aus
Großbritannien und wir sehen hier noch
mal abends ein weiterer Schuss davon
offenbar müssen die Ukrainer sich nicht
mehr zurückziehen und nicht mehr ihre
Artillerie in Sicherheit bringen weil
die Russen so geschwächt sind entlang
der Front dass die Ukrainer gar keine
Angst mehr haben
großen hier direkt auf sie zurück
schießen wir sehen heute morgen wohin
sie schießen nämlich auf Zivilisten in
der ganzen Ukraine
[Musik]